cardi b
gets three piercings in one night
and this is the final result the 27 year
old rapper
filmed the entire piercing process and
posted it to social media on tuesday
night
we see her grin sing and bear it
while being punctured with not one not
two but three new piercings
two on the chest
and one on her bottom lip
luckily she had her hubby offset with
her every step of the way
cardi's changing things up in
self-isolation amid
the coronavirus pandemic from her ever
changing
long af nails
to most recently getting a whole new
look
with a red and now blue pixie do
and we can't forget that epic tattoo
makeover
cardi also admits she's put on some lbs
during quarantine
i see me gain weight maya business we're
eating tacos at 2 am
but the bodak yellow singer shut down
the haters
claiming she's photoshopping her
pictures you know what i'm saying i know
you ain't body shaming me
and in true cardi fashion she proved
this is an edit-free zone by showing off
her
curves irl not once but twice
and i have to do this video because
yesterday i posted a picture too spicy
and i hated claim that i was
photoshopping it so now i gotta
show you this [ __ ] last month
cardi shared her top trick to
mastering the perfect thirst trap
sucking it in
and it seems that things haven't changed
since
hold on i'm i'm actually holding it in
because i ate breakfast lunch and i ate
some ice cream hold on
back again again i'm back at it again
you know what i'm saying it doesn't
matter though
but let's be clear cardi looks amazing
whether she's sucking it in
or not
you